WE TALKED TO RANCHERS, TOO.
THAT'S COMING UP.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME, SIR.
REPUBLICAN FLORES REPRESENTS THE
PEOPLE IN HER DISTRICT OF 34.
SO WE'RE WATCHING, WE'RE
LISTENING ALL OF THIS TOGETHER.
I TAKE IT THAT REPRESENTATIVE
CUELLAR IS TRYING BECAUSE HE
SAYS HE IS, BUT HE IS NOT
SUCCEEDING.
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH DEMOCRATS
IN TEXAS, WHAT IS YOUR REACTION
TO HIM?
>> WELL, WE'RE SICK AND TIRED OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION ACTING LIKE
THIS HUMANITARIAN CRISIS IS NOT
HAPPENING AND WE'RE REALLY
FRUSTRATED BECAUSE THIS ISN'T
JUST A SOUTH TEXAS PROBLEM.
WE NEED ALL SANCTUARY CITIES TO
STEP UP AND HELP US WITH THE
INFLUX OF IMMIGRANTS CROSSING
ILLEGALLY INTO OUR COUNTRY.
WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
COMING IN EVERY SINGLE DAY.
WE HAVE WOMEN AND CHILDREN THAT
HAVE BEEN THROUGH ABUSE, THAT
HAVE BEEN THROUGH RAPE AS WELL
AND THE DANGEROUS JOURNEY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES
TO ENCOURAGE.
THIS MUST STOP.
WE ASK THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
TO COME TO SOUTH TEXAS AND SEE
WHAT HIS POLICIES HAVE DONE TO
US IN SOUTH TEXAS AND WHAT IT IS
DOING TO OUR COUNTRY AS WELL
BECAUSE IT IS NOT JUST THE
INFLUX OF PEOPLE COMING IN.
IT IS ALSO FENTANYL COMING INTO
OUR COUNTRY KILLING OUR YOUTH,
THE FUTURE OF THIS COUNTRY.
>> Harris: REPRESENTATIVE
FLORES, HENRY CUELLAR IS MORE
CONSERVATIVE AT TIMES DEMOCRAT.
HOW ARE THEY EVEN LEADING ON
THIS ISSUE AT ALL IN ANY OF THE
STATES.
HOW ARE THE CONGRESS PEOPLE?
YOU HEAR HIM TALKING THERE.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO HIM?
>> IT'S CLEAR THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT SOUTH TEXAS, DOESN'T EVEN
CARE ABOUT WHAT HENRY CUELLAR IS
SAYING.
THAT SHOULD BE A SIGN TO HENRY
CUELLAR HE SHOULD NO LONGER BE
SUPPORTING THE DEMOCRAT PARTY
THAT DOESN'T EVEN CARE TO HEAR
HIS CRIES AND HIS CONCERNS THAT
HE HAS FOR HIS OWN DISTRICT.
AND HE SHOULD HAVE STEPPED AWAY
FROM THE PARTY THAT NO LONGER
REPRESENTS US IN SOUTH TEXAS.
>> Harris: I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
CAN SEE SOME OF THIS VIDEO BUT
CUELLAR AND OTHER DEMOCRATS HAVE
SAID WE WANT TO LEAVE THINGS
OPEN FOR PEOPLE TO COME HERE
LEGALLY.
WE ARE BEING OVERWHELMED.
THEY KNOW THERE IS NO BARRIER
AND NOTHING THERE.
THERE IS A LEGAL PROCESS
ALREADY.
THERE IS.
IF PEOPLE WANTED TO FOLLOW IT,
THEY WOULDN'T BE THE GIVE UPS ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE RIVER.
YOU REPRESENT DISTRICT 34.
IT HAS 85% HISPANIC POPULATION.
A PLACE THAT WAS DEMOCRAT FOR
100 YEARS UNTIL YOU FLIPPED IT
RED.
NOW NEW POLLING SHOWS THAT BIDEN
AND DEMOCRATS ARE LOSING GROUND
AMONG HISPANIC VOTERS.
IS THIS ISSUE PLAYING ANY KIND
OF A ROLE?
>> ABSOLUTELY IT IS.
I IMMIGRATED TO THIS COUNTRY AND
BLESSED TO COME TO THE UNITED
STATES LEGALLY.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT THE
IMMIGRATION IS BROKEN.
WE DO NEED TO IMPROVE THE LEGAL
PROCESS.
IT TAKES 15 TO 20 YEARS TO BE
ABLE TO COME TO THE UNITED
STATES.
I WAS BLESSED TO HAVE A FATHER
THAT WAS AN AMERICAN CITIZEN
THAT WAS ABLE TO BRING ME
LEGALLY TO THE UNITED STATES.
I BELIEVE WE MUST SECURE THE
BORDERS BUT WE NEED TO IMPROVE
THE LEGAL PROCESS.
WE NEED TO HIRE MORE IMMIGRATION
JUDGES, MORE ASYLUM OFFICERS SO
WE CAN PROCESS THESE CLAIMS.
THE MAJORITY ARE NOT REAL
LEGITIMATE ASYLUM CLAIMS.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO HELP THOSE
WHO ACTUALLY DO HAVE A
LEGITIMATE ASYLUM CLAIM.
I BELIEVE THAT FOCUSING ON LEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND IMPROVING THE
LEGAL PROCESS WE'LL BRING DOWN
THIS HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
BUT AGAIN IT IS THE POLICIES.
WE CAN HIRE MORE BORDER PATROL
AGENTS AND HAVE A WALL AND WE
CAN HAVE TECHNOLOGY BUT IF WE
DON'T ENFORCE THE LAW NOTHING
MATTERS.
WE NEED TO START ENFORCING THE
LAWS THAT WE ALREADY PUT IN
PLACE.
THAT CONGRESS PUT IN PLACE.
WE NEED TO ALSO PUT BACK THE
POLICIES THAT WERE WORKING
BEFORE THIS ADMINISTRATION
BECAUSE WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
SOUTH TEXAS IS BECAUSE OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND IT IS
TIME THAT WE DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS AND OTHER STATES LIKE
CALIFORNIA AND NEW YORK STEP UP.
>> Harris: I THINK ABOUT TWO
GROUPS OF PEOPLE IN TEXAS.
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE YOUR
CONSTITUENTS SAYING TO YOU WE'RE
SPENDING TAXPAYER MONEY,
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS NOW IN
TEXAS, TO DO WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REFUSES TO DO.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE BORDER
PATROL AGENTS, TEXAS DPS AND
OTHERS ARE READY.
NATIONAL GUARD MEMBERS WHO WENT
WITH US AT 1:30 IN THE MORNING.
IT ALL HAS TO BE PAID FOR.
I CAN'T IMAGINE PEOPLE WANT
THEIR TAX DOLLARS SPENT THAT WAY
BUT I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IF IT WEREN'T SPENT THAT
WAY.
>> EXACTLY.
WE ARE USING MILLIONS OF LOCAL
RESOURCES.
WE'RE AT MAX CAPACITY.
WE CAN'T HANDLE THIS ANY MORE.
THE PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING TO PAY
THEIR LIGHT BILLS.
LIGHT BILL JUST TRIPLED.
WENT FROM $300 TO $900 AND
STRUGGLING TO PAY THEIR
UTILITIES AND -- GROCERIES.
WE NEED TO ELECT PEOPLE AND
IMPORTANT FOR US TO SECURE THE
BORDER FOR US TO FOCUS ON THE
DISTRICTS THAT WE REPRESENT.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT
ELECTED US.
IT IS TIME WE PUT THEM FIRST.
>> Harris: THERE YOU GO.
THAT WAS MY SECOND POINT.
HOW UNFAIR IS IT TO THE PEOPLE
LIKE YOURSELF AND OTHERS WHO
COME HERE LEGALLY HAVE TO PUT
PEOPLE FIRST WHO ARE WILLING TO
FOLLOW OUR LAWS.
REPRESENTATIVE FLORES, I KNOW
YOU'RE UP AGAINST ANOTHER
COMPETITION THIS NOVEMBER.
GOOD LUCK TO YOU AND THANK YOU